good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can live
life without regrets
as always guys as you're watching the
clips if you hear somebody say something
that really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around that so other people can
be inspired as well also when you write
it down it's much more likely to stick
with yourself to enjoy
[Music]
the biggest poison in us is regret it's
poison and I push so hard so hard and
we'll through my vehicle which is a
meditation which isn't health and
wellness which is a nonprofit my
vehicles business I can't help it it's
what I love I love building businesses I
love competing with you I want to beat
you I love that game
but through that vehicle I will always
push a lack of regret and awareness to
how good it really is you're more than
welcome to tell me about how bad it is
or why you can't because or what but
it's just not true
because if anybody ever did it then you
can to stop making excuses stop
complaining
nobody's listening they made me pretend
they're listening the market doesn't
care what you need to do is make one
person happy you
then you can make everybody else happy
you know why I like making people happy
because I'm already happy and so I
implore you to take this last little
rant and really look at your face and
understand are you doing the things that
are putting you in a position to succeed
not just in a business world but in life
because it's super important because boy
when you're happy in life your business
can roll
we walk around thinking people look at
us as to star in our movie but they
don't everybody else is living the same
dream though they're walking around in
the star of their own movie and we're
just a filmmaker in their movie so if we
stop taking the actions that we think
will lead towards success because we
think we're worried about what the good
opinion of other people will do to us
I got news for you so listen carefully I
don't get on my soapbox about many
things but I'm getting on it about this
guy's yeah
nobody cares enough about you to bother
to give an opinion because they're too
busy being worried about what they think
you're thinking of them failure failure
is not taking the step failure is not
picking up the battle swinging it at
life failure is getting to the end of
this game I'm regretting what we didn't
do
failure is about saying whatever failure
is lying on your deathbed thinking oh
well if I only I could go back and do
fill in the blank you know something to
me fairly isn't falling down it's
staying down when you fall it you have
to fail by the definition of all I
didn't succeed in order so you can
succeed that's what life is about it's
not about taking it with you at the end
it's not about scorekeeping I probably
failed more times than I've won but I
keep my average number of tries high and
you know what happens guess what you tap
into the lesson of history that most
people ignore and that is this is the
paradox of history but those that risk
the least in life usually end up with
the least in life and just because that
brain won't tell us that when we have to
pay a mortgage on Friday doesn't mean it
isn't true so get up and get in the game
who you are right now watching this is
as a result of your failure is not your
successes it is when we're testing when
the storm is ripping the branches off a
tree you know when the
the rain clouds are there we think we've
got nothing left that's who we are at
our best when we show up when we tested
the strongest trees growing the
strongest winds not in the best soil so
next time you have an opportunity next
time you start a question whether you
should step forward or not or will it be
a white square on the chessboard or a
dark square who cares get in the game
swing the bat be all you can be
get up and if anybody says oh you're
doing that or oh you did that all look
at you failed no this they're failing in
their judgment of you not in your
ability to pick up the baton swing it
again that's the person you were born to
be my friends right that's the person
who you are you were born a miracle you
are good enough you don't need me to
tell you that you already are get out
there get in the game
go embrace it and if you fall over pick
yourself up swing the bat again and
let's go play this game of life what I
decided to do this I I first talked to
my my wife who is sitting here in the
audience and she had married a you know
relatively stable goofy but still
relatively stable a person working at a
Wall Street firm I worked at a
quantitative hedge fund and this was a
hard decision and I was looking for the
right framework in which to make that
kind of important decision and and and
and the right framework I found is a
regret minimization framework and that's
just a nerdy way of saying that you want
to project yourself to age 80 and then
think back over your life and and if
you're if you're if you're 81 or that
you want to minimize the number of
regrets you have throughout that period
of time I think this is something a lot
of people do maybe subconsciously they
probably very few people probably name
it regret minimization framework because
most people are healthier than that but
but it was a very clear way for me to
think about making that kind of life
decision and then and in the way it
helped was I thought okay if I go do
this thing and participate in this thing
called the Internet that I genuinely
believe is gonna be a big deal and if
I fail am I gonna regret having tried
and failed and I knew the answer that
was no but I also knew that if I didn't
try that I would always regret that I
would always wonder and it would haunt
me and until that you know mythical day
one of the greatest problems in life is
that we don't forgive ourselves for the
mistakes that we've made we carry them
around and we beat ourselves up about
them but understand this the person who
did those things in your past is not the
same person that you are today in fact
you are a completely different person
with different experiences and different
knowledge and different wisdom and
different insights the person who did
those things that you still regret is
not you it was a younger version of
yourself almost like another person
altogether so let yourself off the hook
it's all right everyone makes mistakes
whatever happened has happened I'm
afraid deal with it I don't want to deal
with their oh that was me alone my early
journey I have worked in a lot of
shuddhi jobs
and for a long time I was preventing
myself from becoming my greatest version
hanging around with people not living a
lifestyle I'm living right now but if I
think back and say gosh actually I
shouldn't have done that I could have
done that I would have done this
what does that change
you see we often think that we think
longer on a problem is gonna change it
but thinking doesn't actually change
things only radical action so what's
helped me along my journey is to say
okay yeah a lot of my paths
isn't the best but a lot of it is you
see it's always a matter of what you
focus on when dealing with a post slow
motion it's like can I get a hello
a lot of us we only focus on not being
good enough at that period
but right now we're totally different
okay so what's helped me is to realize
that what Evers happened has happened
my only concern right now is where am i
I mean nature baby and there is only
right now that I think the best method
to avoid fear or regret at the time of
death is while we are alive our time our
energy must utilize meaningful way serve
another decisive the most profitable
drug way of what meaning of usefulness
once all survival even animals also it
can do but for service to other is
something unique about human being I
think bondage way
but mother and child or offspring the
bond the bond between mother honestly
even other animals also have but there
are sort of that kind of cross this
feeling short period but we should be
because of intelligence that kind of
feeling we can prolong whole our life X
yes in it travel nah
so serving other people helping other
people is that I think very very
appropriate of action according our
intelligence brain or human ability we
have such our ability so then utilize
that ability posada in the most
appropriate way of most appropriately is
serving other people then at the end you
feel no the credit I done my best some
useful some meaningful life now and come
on oh sorry said but no regret so I'm
with Jeff Bezos on this one I think the
best way to live your life without
regrets is to imagine yourself on your
deathbed looking back at your life and
looking at the situation that you're in
front of right now and asking yourself
am I going to regret not doing this mug
and regret saying no am I gonna regret
being afraid because if you are then you
know you have to go out and do it for me
that's what saved me whenever I'm in a
situation that I'm afraid of doing it's
not don't be afraid because I'll be
afraid it's okay to be afraid but the
thing that gets me through the fear is
that bigger fear of regretting it later
on down the line and be able to make
that mental leap inside your head to
understand that the short-term thing
you're feeling is fear and you don't
just disguise it with a reason because
there's always a practical reason why
you shouldn't do something there's
always a logical reason why you
shouldn't do it and if you can get
through that to understand that that's
not actually the real reason why I'm not
doing it I could deal with those things
I could fix those problems the real
reason is I'm just afraid and then if
you think about your life at the end of
the road looking back on it for me
the best way to do it is to work on
building that muscle where anytime
you're afraid of doing something start
building the muscle at the start you're
gonna be really weak just like anything
else when you start lifting any kind of
weights you're really really weak but as
soon as you find yourself being afraid
of something try to train yourself to
push through it and so I've told the
story about when I was wearing different
colored socks because my son Hayden
7 years old was wearing different
colored socks always has to and so I
wanted to one day wear different colored
socks but it was afraid of what other
people would think and as soon as I
recognized I was only not doing it
because I was afraid of what people
would think then I had to go out and do
it I had to build that muscle or the
time when I'm walking on the street and
I'm dancing and grooving because I got
songs in my ear and I love it and I'm
vibing and then as I get closer to a
main intersection I shrink down and I'm
just doing this because now all those
sudden there's people around me and most
of the time we shrink down without even
noticing it's so subconscious it's so
natural to shrink down it's so natural
to play the smaller game because you're
concerned about what other people think
and as soon as I caught myself saying
wait why am i why am I playing the
smaller game here why am I so afraid
well concern about what are these people
gonna think if I'm busting out some
dance moves so as soon as I recognized
that I was holding myself back because
of the fear of other people's judgments
then I had to go and dance bigger I had
to go and groove it out on the street
and dance and build a muscle and so
anytime you catch yourself doing
something and the only reason is because
you're afraid of it work on building
that muscle because the last thing that
I want for any of you and the last thing
I want for myself and the people around
me is to be on my deathbed however old
that's going to be looking back in my
life looking back on this moment and
regretting that I played small because I
was afraid build your muscle
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this beauty because Geeta asked me
to so there's a topic you'd like me to
cover in the next edition I believe life
leave it down the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I love to know
what did you think of this video what
was the clip that inspired you the most
what did you learn from this that you're
going to immediately apply somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
in the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion I'd
also love to know how do you live life
without regrets what are some of your
strategies that maybe haven't been
covered in this video yet that you want
to share that may help alleviation and
people watch it as well leave it down in
the comments and do a good public
service finally I wanted to give a quick
shout out to Thelma Saunders Thelma
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and posting it
to Twitter as well
I really really appreciate the support
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is
much love have an amazing day and I'll
see you soon
I don't think I would change anything
because I think it's important to go
through life with without any regrets
people have said to me would you change
98 would you change the red card against
Argentina do I wish it hadn't have
happened of course but if it hadn't have
happened would I have been the player
that I am today would have been a strong
person on the field and off the field
that I am today so there's nothing
nothing I regret everything happens for
a reason how many times have people told
you that and it's really annoying right
now don't tell me that now why do people
say this because subconsciously we know
it's the truth what helped me along my
journey was to start connecting the dots
I now realize everything that I went
through
everything have gone through has led me
up to where I am today I gotta thank
those study jobs my irresponsible
behavior and it's going to continue to
be very irresponsible right it's gonna
continue to be very irresponsible there
it there are no Saints here baby is they
in the Brady Bunch
okay so you got to have a sense of human
you got to realize that okay everything
you are going through is preparing you
for the next step is what I call coming
off your righteous high horse now I
share a lot and it's very introspective
that's why I always say this is what's
helped me along my journey
everybody has to realize nobody has it
all figured out
even though I'm a psychologist I inspire
millions I'm still evolving but I
realize if I can realize that it's okay
okay the past is okay even if it's
really grimy even if we even if you had
even if you want to put a blindfold on
that's fine but realize that was meant
to happen why because it did there are
no accidents or coincidences in this
universe ever
everything is in divine order I accept
that
I'm not in resistance to them powerful
mantra right there